foreign
recently for the very first time in my
in my life went to Bucky's now if you've
heard about Bucky's it is a gas station
chain that's been Regional they're
spreading now and I went to one in
Athens Alabama for the first time heard
a lot of Buzz about it people are
freaking out and I'm going I don't
understand it's a gas station like how
could this be life-changing yeah no no
before we go any further when I want
people to fully understand the hype
around this if because we have a lot of
people listening from a lot of places
watching from a lot of places
this thing certainly in the South
Southeast has taken on like this crazy
thing kids are buying my kid I have
three teenagers all right their friends
are showing up at my house with Bucky
backpacks Bucky sweatshirts I mean it is
now they have one they have won the
brand War oh yeah like it is no longer a
roadside convenience store gas station
this is an experience for people well in
Christmas time there was all these
inflatable Bucky beavers out in yards
yeah Santa's out Bucky's is in yeah
something about Bucky and and the Beaver
but really it's about uh the the culture
of the entire place now full disclosure
I've not been in one but everybody else
in my family has and so I've heard
firsthand how unbelievable it is from
the way it looks the way it feels the
stuff on the shelves I mean uh one of
our co-workers here got introduced me to
a bag of beaver nuggets legendary I
didn't know what a beaver nugget was
caramel coated Corn Pop snack there it
is that's what it is so Ken I had a bad
attitude going into this yeah you were a
little snarky weren't you yeah it was I
was like let's see what's special about
this and special Ken I walked in there
what was special about it first of all
the employees are incredible they're
happy to be there they're doing a great
job the place is clean it's amazingly
stocked they're cooking up fresh brisket
they have the most amazing selection
they've got you know Bucky's branded
snacks that I'm just learning about for
the first time it was it was like an
adult Disney World
and uh even better Ken here's what where
you come into this
on my way out I see a sign that they're
hiring and it was amazing let's put that
sign up that they've got out there and
here's what's amazing no experience
necessary the lowest paying job at
Bucky's is 17 bucks the general managers
make 150 to 225
thousand yeah I heard you wow no
experience necessary they got a 401k 100
match up to six percent three weeks paid
time off immediately you can use it cash
it roll at Healthcare they've got
part-time jobs you get an extra two
bucks for the overnight shift and it
just made me go there is hope for for
the job you know economy in America
today well you know I'm glad you're
bringing this up because first of all
folks the job economy is really hot
unemployment's back down to 3.5 percent
wages at an all-time high I just looked
at the sign it said the car wash manager
makes 125. thousand 125 000 to be the
car wash manager at Bucky's
stop griping
I can't get ahead go to Bucky's and be a
car wash manager
well Ken there's a lot of that's the
lesson well there's an anti-work
mentality out there there's very
pessimistic very cynical towards the
idea of employment in general and when I
walked in that I went these people are
excited to be here they've got a great
culture number one that's right and
great pay great benefits and they're
doing work that matters that's exactly
right by the way let's let's talk about
that
when we say work that matters and then I
talk about this all the time with the
Ken commission I'm the work guy here at
Ramsey right and I just believe that you
were created to contribute to your work
in other words what's the difference
that you want to make in the world
what were you born to do you you're just
hardwired with Talent you got a heart
there's a type of work function you love
to do and you care about making a
difference in the world and and we've
made we've made like success in work
this unicorn with wings
and it's like how can I join myself and
the fact of the matter is some of those
people are really in their dream job and
it's not because it's sexy or that it
pays a million dollars it's just they
really enjoy showing up every day and
they enjoy it while they're there
and they can see a result
that they care about and no experience
necessary means I didn't need to go get
a four-year degree because of the
pressure from parents and Society to
then have to get a job that pays 30
grand that I'm miserable in this is the
trend of 2023 right here what's that
companies are now hiring
for skill not for qualification in other
words they're going to hire you based on
can I train you to be the car wash
manager at Bucky's not I have a degree
in automobile cleansing
there it's it's less about the degree
companies are dropping degree
requirements and they're going we're
going to hire for skill in other words
what they're really saying is if we feel
you have the Raw Talent and you get some
good character we're going to train you
to have the skills you need this is the
new trend folks and and it should be
encouraging for those of you out there
who feel like you're dealing with
imposter syndrome you got some doubt
because you go I can't make the kind of
money I want to make because I didn't go
to a to a to a steak and Sizzle School
I I didn't go to an Ivy League school or
I didn't go to the biggest school I
don't even have a degree at all Ken well
guess what the playing field is being
leveled companies are saying we just
want good people we'll train them how to
do the job and Bucky's is an example
they're saying it in their ads they're
going no experience required what what
isn't that lovely well I think companies
are now hiring for character competency
that's it and they're going we can hire
yeah we can teach you how to do the job
that's fine but do you have the people
skills do you have the soft skills the
hard skills all those pieces coming
together to then create a job did you
get your car washed by the way I didn't
we were in a rush it was in and out I
got some brisket got out of there but
man I wish I could have stayed for hours
to be honest well and what people need
to understand is is what a quality
company looks like and sounds like it
feels like and this is it the people are
happy the environment is nice there's a
direct correlation between happy excited
enthusiastic people and a clean
energetic environment you could ate a
meal off that bathroom floor it says a
lot to me that George Campbell the
George camel that I've known for quite
some time bought brisket at Bucky's in
fact that's my biggest surprise of 2023
so far and I I dare say at the end of
2023 you'll still be at the top of the
list I've been described as bougie you
know and so people go you're going to
get brisket from a gas State no don't
look at it like that this was the
highest quality brisket known to man
you're Persnickety and it was cut to
Perfection the barbecue sauce can was
rich flavorful I gotta tell you this is
not a free ad for Bucky's but it really
is because folks George George walking
into any gas station off of any
Interstate exit is like the doctor
walking into surgery he's got more
anti-back on him than a human should be
allowed Wow way to go Bucky I love some
anti-back what's the lesson there's a
whole lot of opportunity in America
today for you to make the money you want
to make you just gotta go get it
speaking of money we got to pay some
bills we'll be right back this is the
Ramsay